[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic la supersymétrie
qu est ce qu une symétrie
une symétrie et d'une transformation qui
n'affecte pas un objet une sphère est
symétrique par rotation un papillon par
réflexion une grille par translation
identifier les symétries d'un objet
permet de comprendre sa structure
géométrique
il s'avère que l'univers présente lui
aussi des symétries les lois de la
nature ne change pas après certaines
transformations
par exemple la physique ne change pas
d'un point à l'autre de l'espace
l'univers est symétrique par translation
autre exemple si on réalise une
expérience dans une direction le
résultat est le même si on réalise
l'expérience dans une autre direction
l'univers est symétrique par rotation
en identifiant des symétries de plus en
plus complexes les physiciens ont affiné
notre compréhension du monde
[Musique]
mais at-on identifier toutes les
symétries de l'univers en reste-t-il de
nouvelles à découvrir peut-être bien la
supersymétrie est justement un nouveau
genre de symétrie que l'on n'a pour
l'instant jamais observée
[Musique]
commençons par revoir rapidement nos
modèles actuels
de nos jours on décrit l'univers comme
un bloc l'espace temps dans lequel
évoluent des particules 1 il existe deux
familles de particules que l' on
classifie dans le modèle standard d'une
part les fermions qui constituent la
matière
d'autre part les bosons qui véhicule les
interactions
la supersymétrie postule que le modèle
standard serait incomplet qu'il
existerait d'autres particules encore
jamais observées chaque particule du
modèle standard aurait un super
partenaire dans l'autre catégorie si
bien qu'il y aurait un nouveau besoin
pour chaque fermier et un nouveau
fermions pour chaque bozon
les fermions électrons quark neutrinos
auraient chacun un partenaire dans la
famille des bosons selectron squarc ce
notre hinault et les bosons photons plus
haut zad w boson de higgs auraient
chacun un partenaire dans la famille des
fermions fautino gouineau zino we know
it zino
la supersymétrie et cette symétrie
encore hypothétique entre les particules
de matière et d'interaction
les chercheurs s'intéressent à cette
hypothèse car elle pourrait résoudre un
grand nombre de problèmes en postulant
l'existence de nouvelles particules la
supersymétrie propose par exemple des
candidats prometteurs pour expliquer la
nature de la matière noire cette masse
invisible dont on ne connaît pas encore
la composition
autre exemple on pense qu'au moment du
big bang il y à 13,8 milliards d'années
l'électromagnétisme l'interaction forte
et l'interaction faible trois des quatre
interactions fondamentales de l'univers
étaient fusionnées et n'en former qu'une
seule
de nos jours ces trois interactions des
intensités différentes mais en remontant
le temps jusqu'au big bang les trois
forces devrait tendre vers une même
valeur c'est la grande unification
une idée qui permettrait de se
rapprocher d'une théorie du tout
malheureusement les calculs du modèle
standard semble indiquer que les trois
courbes se rate
en ajoutant la supersymétrie les calculs
prédisent cette fois ci que les courbes
se réunissent en accord avec la grande
unification
[Musique]
mais pourquoi les physiciens se
concentrent utile principalement sur la
supersymétrie
on pourrait penser que d'autres symétrie
y sont tout autant intéressante à
étudier
en réalité seule la supersymétrie semble
être une hypothèse raisonnable
pour comprendre nous allons devoir nous
replonger dans nos modèles actuels
d'une part la trame de l'univers est
décrite comme une immense grille
l'espace-temps
l'espace-temps possède des symétries les
lois de l'univers sont invariante d'un
point à l'autre d'une orientation à
l'autre d'un instant à un autre et d'un
référentiel inertielle un autre
l'espace temps respecte ces quatre
symétrie qu'on appelle les symétries de
poincaré ce sont les symétries de la
relativité restreinte
[Musique]
d'autre part l'univers est peuplé de
particules que l'on décrit comme des
perturbations dans des champs quantique
il existe un champ quantique pour chaque
type de particule un champ pour les
électrons un champ pour les photons et
ainsi de suite
ces chants quantiques sont des sortes de
fluides mathématiques qui remplissent
tout l'espace
le chant du boson de higgs est formé de
nombre les champs d autres bozon sont
formés de vecteurs et les chants des
fermions sont constitués de spinner des
objets mathématiques étrange qui
décrivent très bien ce type de
particules
on distingue ces trois types de champs
par une propriété qu'on appelle le spin
0 et 1 pour les bosons et spin 1/2 pour
les fermiers
le spin est directement liée au type
d'objets mathématiques qui constituent
ces chants quantique
[Musique]
pour bien appréhender les fondements de
la supersymétrie faisons une parenthèse
technique
les champs quantique associé au boson
sont décrits par des nombres ou des
vecteurs de nombre
dans le monde des nombres la
multiplication et commutative si l'on
prend de nombre comme 3 et 5 3 x 5 égale
15 et 5 x 3 égale 15 plus généralement x
x y et gale y x x
mais les szpiner quant à eux qu'ils
décrivent les fermions ne sont pas
constitués de nombre mais d'autres
objets plus étrange qu'on appelle des
nombres de grasmann
malgré leur nom ces nombres de grasmann
ne sont pas vraiment des nombres ce sont
des outils mathématiques abstrait dans
le monde des nombres de grasmann à x b
est égal à - b fois à
les nombres de grasmann son anti
commutatif et en conséquence un nombre
de grasmann au carré vaut toujours zéro
c'est une propriété très étrange qui
n'était évidemment pas valable avec des
nombres ordinaire mais un peu comme les
nombres complexes on peut construire de
tels objets abstrait dans le cadre des
mathématiques il s'avère très utile pour
décrire les particules de matière
c'est cette différence entre les
nombreux ordinaires et les nombres de
grâce man qui distingue est
fondamentalement les fermions des
votants on peut multiplier un nombre
ordinaires par lui même ce qui implique
en pratique que deux bozon identiques
peuvent être au même endroit en même
temps mais il est impossible de faire la
même chose avec deux fermions car on ne
peut pas multiplier un nombre de
grasmann par lui même on obtient
forcément 0
c'est le principe d'exclusion de paoli
2 fermions ne peuvent pas être
simultanément dans un même état
cela explique que l'on ne traverse pas
une chaise lorsqu'on s'assoit les
électrons de nos atomes ne pouvant pas
passer les uns à travers les autres
[Musique]
fermons la parenthèse et revenons au
symétrie
on a vu que l'espace temps obéit à 4
symétrie les symétries de poincaré
mais certains champs quantique possède
également des symétries les quark par
exemple existe en trois versions rouge
vert et bleu qui sont interchangeables
il s'agit d'une symétrie interne au
chant des quark
un autre exemple les chants des
particules chargées comme les électrons
sont invariants lorsqu'on modifie la
phase des nombres complexes
[Musique]
il s'agit d'un autre exemple de symétrie
interne asséchant quantique
[Musique]
en 1967 les physiciens coleman et
manjula vont démontrer mathématiquement
que l'univers ne peut obéir à aucun
autre type de symétrie les seuls types
de symétrie possibles sont celles de
poincaré issus de la structure de
l'espace temps lsi maîtrise interne
propre à chaque chant quantique
le théorème interdit tout nouveau type
de symétrie
mais en 1971 golf hand et l'ict man
découvre une faille le théorème de
coleman et manjula se base sur une
hypothèse il suppose que tout les
symétries sont quantifiés par des
nombres
pour contourner cette hypothèse golf
hand et l'ict man imagine une symétrie
d'un genre nouveau qui ne serait pas
décrite par des nombres mais par des
nombres de grasmann
dans cette situation le théorème de
coleman et manjula ne s'applique pas il
n'interdit pas une telle symétrie c'est
la supersymétrie
dans nos modèles actuels elle serait la
seule extension possible aux types de
symétrie que l'on connaît déjà
une façon intuitive de visualiser la
supersymétrie est d'imaginer que
l'espace temps est séparé en deux copies
l'une fait de nombre et l'autre fait de
nombre de grasmann
dans l'une évoluent les bosons
dans l'autre les fermer en
la supersymétrie est l'idée qu'il
existerait une symétrie par translation
d'un espace temps vers l'autre
une translation qui interverti nombre et
nombre de grasmann bozon et fermions
cette image n'est d'ailleurs pas anodine
on parle de super espaces
d'un point de vue mathématique on peut
décrire l'univers comme deux espaces
complémentaires l'un pour les nombres
l'autre pour les nombres de grâce man et
chaque chant quantique existerait dans
tout ce super espace si bien que chaque
particule aurait une partenaire dans
l'autre catégorie
il s'agit d'une représentation abstraite
mais puissante pour décrire la
supersymétrie
lorsqu'elle fut théorisée on espérait
que la supersymétrie puisse résoudre un
problème crucial la masse du boson de
higgs
en effet le boson de higgs interagit
avec les particules virtuelles du vide
quantique et selon les calculs toutes
ces interactions devraient lui procurer
une masse considérable mais dans la
pratique il s'avère beaucoup plus léger
la supersymétrie était censé apporter
une solution à ce problème en ajoutant
des supers particules le vide quantique
serait rempli d'autant de fermions que
de bozon et leur contribution et tente
opposée elles s'annihilent ray
malheureusement pour que cette
explication fonctionnent les particules
partenaires doivent avoir des masses
très similaire pour que leur
contribution s'équilibre or à l'heure
actuelle aucun super partenaire n'a
encore été détecté ce qui indique que
s'il existe c'est super partenaires sont
forcément plus massif que ce qu'on
pensait autrement il aurait déjà dû être
détecté
en d'autres termes notre univers ne
semble pas respecté la supersymétrie du
moins dans sa forme la plus exacte les
particules supersymétriques existe
peut-être mais elle aurait
nécessairement une masse plus élevé que
leurs partenaires
les chercheurs se demandent aujourd'hui
si l'univers respectait la supersymétrie
lors de ces premiers instants juste
après le big bang
l'ayant ensuite brisé en se
refroidissant
pour résumer après des décennies de
recherche la supersymétrie reste une
hypothèse dont on sait qu'elle n'est pas
valide sous sa forme la plus idéale mais
elle reste un sujet de recherche
cruciale puisqu'elle est potentiellement
la seule nouvelle symétrie qui n'est pas
interdite par le modèle actuel
la supersymétrie introduit une dualité
entre les besoins et les fermiers qui
pourrait résoudre de nombreux mystères
et dont le formalisme mathématique a
permis des avancées dans de multiples
domaines
attention la supersymétrie n'est pas une
théorie elle est simplement un type de
symétrie que pourrait ou non respecté
notre univers
plusieurs modèles supposent la
supersymétrie et en la mettant à
l'épreuve expérimentalement on peut
restreindre ses modèles et affiner nos
recherches
elle est utilisée dans la théorie des
supercordes l'une des approches les plus
prometteuses pour unifier la relativité
générale et la physique quantique les
particules y sont décrites comme de
minuscules corde vibrante qui
posséderait une supersymétrie le long de
leur surface
elle est également à la base de la
supergravité un modèle qui combinent à
supersymétrie et relativité générale et
prédit un super partenaire pour le
graviton la particule de gravité le
gravity no
enfin on peut construire des modèles
d'univers avec plusieurs supersymétrie
mais il existe une limite au nombre de
symétrie que l'on peut ajouter on parle
de super gravité maximal
dans un tel modèle si l'espace temps
avait onze dimensions tout les
constantes de l'univers s'avérerait
déterminée uniquement par ses symétrie
[Musique]
un modèle qui fut découvert en france
dans les années 1970
la version quantique de ce modèle
proposé par whitten en 1995 pourrait
unifier toutes les versions de la
théorie des cordes c'est la théorie m
[Musique]